okay i have no idea if anybody's gonna
care about this but i care about it so
i'm making a video on it the blade movie
has a casting call that's going on right
now for a woman of north african descent
and she's supposed to play a significant
role in the film now given everything
that we know about blade which is almost
nothing so far but the fact that blade
was talking to dane whitman as a post
credit scene in the eternals all that
kind of stuff there's only one person
that comes to mind and i'm not the only
one guessing this a lot of other people
are speculating as this person as well
that is faisa hussein okay if it's this
girl
it's a whole different beast right so
this girl's name was basically excalibur
right that was the code name she used
here's kind of a fun fact by the way uh
black knight dane whitman he's descended
from sir percy of scandia right he's one
of the original knights of the round
table like all that stuff exists in the
comics and it exists in the mcu now
presumably right like king arthur
camelot guinevere merlin excalibur the
knights of the round table all that kind
of stuff that's all real in the comics
it's all in other world right but like
it's all basically a thing that
presumably exists now what would be
hilarious is if they brought in king
arthur and the knights of justice do you
guys remember that cartoon show for back
of the day
[Music]
the show was terrible but the intro
slapped but the important thing here
right back on track back outside i don't
want to digress too bad faiza is an
absolute
hoss right this girl has done so much
stuff she killed dracula at one point in
time using excalibur she was an agent of
mi13 she was basically the steward of
dane whitman and in fact they had a kind
of thing going on for a little while
like there's a lot of history there
right so
the big question to ask here is if
they're casting this girl in blade
doesn't matter right like is this a girl
that we should concern ourselves with
like is she a powerful person or
anything like that
absolutely okay so so here's the idea
behind phasing right here's the whole
the whole thing minor character and
maybe we'll probably end up doing like a
full-on character explanation on her
over comics explained once her name gets
dropped but the thing about this is she
debuted in secret invasion right now a
lot of you guys know about secret
invasion if for no other reason than the
fact that it's like the next big event
the marvel cinematic universe is doing
it's getting a tv show presumably that
show will cross over with other aspects
of the mcu the the secret invasion event
was huge when it happened in the comics
so i have a hard time believing it'll
just be confined to a show and that'll
be it because literally the secret
invasion event was essentially humanity
learning that the scroll race had been
replacing superheroes like captain
america and like the x-men of the
fantastic four and iron man and people
like that like big names right it wasn't
like secret invasion was an event that
involved like alpha flight from canada
right if you guys don't know who they
are that's fine that team sucks but the
the thing here is that faza debuted
during that storyline now the whole idea
of secret invasion was a worldwide event
but it wasn't just in the states right
scrolls were replacing people all over
the world and so while you had like the
big battle of new york with like nick
fury and like daisy johnson quake of
course a lot of you guys probably know
her she was played by chloe bennett and
agents of shield different things like
that you had pretty much like the
traditional avengers roster new avengers
mighty avengers so on and so forth over
in london you had faiza who was
basically a doctor right like she was a
field medic that was treating people
when like this great big huge battle and
everything was going on during this
whole conflict initially dane whitman
had been incapacitated and that faiza
tended to his wounds but they were both
hit by what was basically this massive
source of energy from the scrolls what
it did is it granted her these powers
that gave her the ability to essentially
manipulate and deconstruct matter on the
atomic level organic and inorganic alike
it doesn't matter and so in this
instance dane whitman had suffered from
injuries she was able to use her powers
to basically restructure his body right
to like fixed broken bones different
things like that because by way of her
powers she intuitively knows how things
are supposed to work right so say for
example that you ran up on faza and you
said my arm is broken right like my arm
is totally shattered into like 20 pieces
is there anything you can do assuming
that you weren't in so much pain that
you would just pass out from shock right
that you were somehow capable of telling
her this uh then literally she would
examine your arm and then she would
basically reconstruct your arm because
she would know exactly how you're almost
supposed to look right how how your bow
i mean bones are pretty for the most
part universal but you guys get what i
mean right and she can do this with both
organic and inorganic metals so like if
she came over to your house and
accidentally knocked over a priceless
voss she could restructure it right she
knows exactly how it's supposed to look
so that kind of a thing now why does
this matter because while i wouldn't go
as far as to say that she's going to
have an initial introduction alongside
dane whitman otherwise it wouldn't make
any sense to have her in blade she's
going to be alongside blake the fact
that she wielded the excalibur sword in
the comics the fact that she killed
dracula with excalibur in the comics all
points to this idea that like because
mi13 in the comics was basically the
british government's version of a team
that faced off against supernatural
threats that she would go in and fight
alongside blake and she would be a huge
asset to fight alongside blake now
whether or not she's going to be there
for the long term we don't know we don't
even know she's going to have any powers
we simply just know that she's there
right it could just be that she's going
to be someone akin to rosario dawson
when she played night nurse on the
netflix series for like daredevil and
all those different shows right so
literally she's there like blade is
injured and she's like the attending
medic for some reason or whatever it is
and like maybe she treats people who
have powers in the same way that like
night nurse treated superheroes and
different things along those lines right
who really knows here the important
thing is that she's gonna be in this
movie the fact that she's here means
they can build on her they can turn her
into something bigger we already know
with blade and then with ghost riders
scheduled to show up in uh in doctor
strange multiverse and madness we know
werewolf by night is getting a show that
the marvel cinematic universe is already
building up to like the midnight suns
right we know we're already getting that
it's only a matter of time before we see
a completed team i mean literally
fighting them in the mcu have been like
yeah man midnight suns is coming right
and i am so excited i am so excited
about the midnight suns i love midnight
suns right it's just it's such a
phenomenal
it's such a it's just
it's a great team right uh 13 is the
british version of that right like they
face off against superhero threats not
the traditional midnight sun's roster
but dealing with like monsters and
different things on those lines vampires
and stuff like that mi13 handles that
and so while i wouldn't really go as far
as to say that having faiza hussein in
the marvel cinematic universe in blade
is gonna be like this stepping stone to
her leading her own superhero based team
it's it's the marvel cinematic universe
expanding especially doing it overseas
then when you take into account the idea
that like she had fought alongside
captain britain a few times now you got
brian braddock that you could throw into
the mix but with regards to the
conflicts of her involvement with blade
it'll only ever really go one of two
ways either she will have something of a
role where she already has her powers or
she's like an attending medic or
something like that where she's like the
equivalent of chris christopherson's uh
whistler from like the wesley snipes
blade movies if you guys remember that
she plays a role similar to that not
really the tech side but like the
healing side helping him get over his
injuries he sustains and things like
that against vampires if his healing
factor is simply just not working fast
enough and so on or she's going to be
someone who's just kind of there she
plays some sort of a role in some
capacity that we really don't know what
it's going to be without any kind of
powers or any involvement in blade
himself but the fact that they're saying
that it's supposed to be a role of
significance a role that's supposed to
be pretty big in the film indicates that
she probably already has her powers now
will her powers be on the same level as
they are in the comics probably not and
it's not really just because of the fact
that the mcu is sliding phaser or
anything like that that's universal
across the board nobody in the marvel
cinematic universe is ever as powerful
as they are in the comics that's why as
much as we would love to see like the
actual world war hulk right like world
breaker hulk or even like heart of the
monster hulk who was powerful enough to
shatter dimensions even though we want
to see somebody like that we'll probably
see it just not on the same level which
really begs the question why even do it
at all right that's universal across the
board when it comes to the marvel
cinematic universe they're never as
powerful as their comic book
counterparts so i imagine face uh would
likely just have the ability to heal and
that'll basically be it right she'll
have the ability to heal other people
and that's really all there is to it
right and then she would basically
follow blade around right help him out
on different adventures and skirmish and
conflicts and so on and so forth and
like that would basically be it right
you know he she would treat his injuries
and the two of them would kill vampires
together and maybe he saved her from a
vampire or saved her from dracula or
something like that and like that's all
you really get from the character but
she's just kind of a side along right
just being there alongside blade so i
don't know let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section
though because i feel like having her
there is great because one of the things
that i love about the marvel cinematic
universe and i've loved it since the
beginning is they take obscure
characters and they make them popular
right they make them great like none of
you guys would have heard of echo if you
didn't read marvel comics right i was
just that's just the way that it is
right like the marvel cinematic universe
had to convince people that iron man was
not a robot most people had no idea who
bucky barnes was most people knew of
black panther but had no knowledge of
black panther's history in the comics in
terms of like wakanda then acropolis
right like ulysses claw all that kind of
stuff so it's cool to see them take
these elements and just bolster them up
and turn them into something cool but
let me know what you guys think does the
character of phases sound cool to you do
you want to see her do you not really
care let me know what you guys think
down in the comments thank you all for
watching and i'll catch you all later
peace